today i want to talk about the
complicated relationship between ronnie
the witch and ranalla queen of caglia
and the governor of the academy of
riyadh lucaria of course most of this is
pure speculation from interpreting the
story of elden ring and the
environmental storytelling of the lands
between the lore of this game is based
on the findings and interpretations of
the community so please comment below on
any findings you may have had so we all
know that ronnie is the daughter of
ranala and radagon ratagon sailed to the
lands between in search of more lands to
conquer once he found the lands between
he first met queen ranala in battle
after first meeting her he fell in love
with her and renounced his old ways of
conquering during this marriage they had
a child we know as ronnie however
radagon eventually left ranala and
instead married queen marika this
marriage raised ronnie's status to that
of a demigod and now being an emperian
rani has been chosen by the two fingers
as a potential successor to queen marca
along with marcus when children melania
and michela imperian meaning born that
of a god and ronnie is still considered
half and perion because she is the
daughter of ratagon ranala being a
powerful sorcerer in her own right is
still not considered a god however
ronnie did not want to subject herself
to the bidding of the two fingers it is
theorized that because of this ronnie
plotted with her assassins and was the
mastermind behind the knight of black
knives to break free from the two
fingers ronnie needed to break her
worldly and bodily ties during the night
of black knives she stole the rune of
death from her half-brother godwin the
prince of death to make sure only her
body would be slain she simultaneously
used the rune of death on herself
killing her body in the process and the
other half was used on her half-brother
godwin which killed him in spirit we can
see the disgusting aftermath of this
process on godwin as his body has been
twisted and mangled with no spirit to
guide it we can find the first half of
the rune of death on ronnie's discarded
body which can be found at the top of
the carrion study hall tower the other
half can be found after completing fia's
questline directly underneath godwin's
mangled body deep within the roots of
the earth tree but why would ronnie do
this yes she wants to break free from
the control of the two fingers and
pursue her divine ascension breaking the
golden order and ushering in a new era
of darkness under the full moon that's a
pretty good reason but i think there's
more to it because what actions could
have instigated her to do this and in my
mind i think it can be vengeance driven
on behalf of her mother ranala ranala
was once a powerful sorceress and still
is to this day but is now taken over by
the rebirthing process of her children
and has in my opinion gone mad from pure
heartbreak it is unknown why ratagon
decided to leave ranala but that's
something we can all relate to most of
us will go through a heartbreak at one
point or another in our lives it's not
fun and can lead to some serious mental
health issues and my theory is that
ronald no longer sees her current self
as worthy of ratagon and is constantly
trying to rebirth herself to
legitimately remake herself over and
over again until one birth can be seen
as worthy to ratagon but as we can see
during her boss fight this rebirth
process has gone horribly wrong over and
over again these children we see are
different variations of ranala herself
desperately attempting to make a version
of herself that can be deemed worthy
she's clearly not in the right frame of
mind so ronnie decides to make a spell
to protect her mother this is what we
see in stage two of the ranala boss
fight we don't fight ranala herself we
fight a summon of ranala's most powerful
self which was cast and placed by ronnie
ronnie likely knew the shattering of the
elven ring was close at hand we know
this from ronnie's dialogue during stage
two of ranala's boss fight
of the last queen
she calls her mother the last queen of
carya meaning there will be no other
queens to follow her with the shattering
of the elden ring there will be no kings
or queens but an entirely new order
under the night of the full moon so
while plotting her own mission to take
the rune of death and start the night of
black knife assassins she chose to seal
her mother away inside the academy and
protect her from the war taking place
outside the academy she forced her
half-brother godwin to take half the
rune of death to discard his spirit so
that she could keep her own this could
be an attempt at revenge for her mother
killing a son of ratagon who chose to
leave her once the shattering took place
it was a free-for-all for the demi-god
children of radagon and marca to seek
power from the ruins of the elden ring
while queen marika disappeared after the
shattering of the ring and we still
don't know why queen marika decided to
shatter the ring itself but ratagon
stayed behind to attempt to mend the
ring back together and restore the
golden order it's up to us in the
decisions that we make in the game to
seek the fate of the lands between and
the entire world and it's very
interesting to think that this all may
have started from the heartbreak of a
mother and the vengeance of a protective
daughter to take back their power and
never be controlled by another again we
as the player and a tarnished of no
renown
never question the actions of why we
should become the elden lord ronnie uses
our power as a tarnished to pursue what
she wants you could argue that we choose
this path of our own free will but i
believe even well before the game came
out in the story trailer of elden ring
ronnie was manipulating us to become
elden lord or her
[Music]
unless of course
thou should take the crown
[Music]
oh
you